Right? So if you're Dana, you're like,
listen, look at Conor like getting ideas.
When they get this boatload of money,
we can't give them to fight.
They have power. The sports
too hard. They won't do it. Hm.
That's interesting. I know. So to keep, to
keep 'em hungry, we got to pay him this.
It's so fucked up.
I'm not saying it's the right thing to do,
but I'm saying if your day,
and from his standpoint you're like,
when they get fat highly, they don't
fight way. They really think that way.
I don't think that's the case.
You don't think it's a side effect
of making boat loads of money.
But I think they try to make boatloads
of money cause it doesn't happen very
often.
It only happens with a Rhonda Rousey
or Conor McGregor or some gigantic huge
star like a Nate Diaz. Did. You have to
be a gigantic from site. Yeah, but that's,
that's rare. There's so few of
those guys. There's so few of those.
The idea that you would try to pay
people less because you want to keep them
hungry. Because if they become giant
superstars and they're not hungry,
then they stopped fighting. They were
not pay him more. So they had him.
What you're saying is pretend you're
not there, not giant superstars.
Even when they are know the
giant superstars still get paid,
but they also have crazy
demands. They, they,
they want to find who they want to fight.
They want to do it when
they want to do it.
And there's all sorts of jockeying
going on back and forth. I mean,
I don't know what happened with
Nate Diaz and Dustin Poirier,
but they were supposed to
fight, let's fight. And then,
and Dustin got injured, but,
so Nate was scheduled for a fight and
he's never pulled out of a fight that he's
been scheduled for as
far as I can remember.
He was going to fight that fight and
then went to an APP and that made other
offers. You just like, I'm good. Right?
But let's imagine that if Dustin poray
did not pull out of that fight, would,
if he did fight Nate Diaz and would,
if Nate Diaz beat him,
the Nate Diaz could very well have fought
Max Holloway maybe Saturday night. Yes.
Maybe. Maybe. Yeah. If you
paid them enough, it might
may be. I'm sure he would aid.
They might've decided to make that shit
happen, you know? And you know what?
I bet it would have been. Yeah, that
was it. That was the face to face off.
I bet out would've been a very
entertaining fight to God. Oh my God.
Acts and Nate Diaz with both Simon's
insane cardio insane volume striking.
That would be an incredible fight,
man. Fuck. That would be a great fun.
That'd be a great fight. Yeah. Max
and Nick would have been insane,
but Max was going to fight Dustin
Poirier and you know, he could be looked.
That'll be a big fight. Dustin
Poirier. If he doesn't fight Khabib,
if for whatever reason they decide to
go with Nate over could be, they're not,
they're going to do, could be
next. Yeah, in September. Wow.
Maybe could be fights the winter
or the winter, rather fights Nate.
That could be possible too.
If he really still weren't Tony Ferguson,
Tony Ferguson.